question Randy yes good to have you this
afternoon and we do have a number of
questions that we'll be sharing but
before we do so do you mind leading Us
in an opening prayer of course
the Father in heaven we come into your
presence to thank you for the high honor
of serving you cleanse our hearts from
sin I pray and Grant to us the wisdom
promised in James chapter 1 verse 5. if
any of you lack wisdom let him ask of
God that giveth to all men liberally
give to us that wisdom now I pray that
we may present your word clearly bless
those who will watch I ask in Jesus name
amen
our first question today pasta is is it
true that one can see God cannot see God
and leave especially as you look at the
example of Israel didn't he see God and
yet lived the Bible is very clear in
Exodus 33 in verse 18 Moses said I
beseech thee show me thy Glory he wanted
to see the brightness the Brilliance of
God
God said in verse 19 I will make all my
goodness pass before thee and I will
proclaim the name of the Lord before
Thee I will be gracious to whom I will
be gracious I will show Mercy on whom I
will show mercy and he said thou canst
not see my face for they can no man see
me and live then he put Moses in the
cleft of rock and he told me in verse 23
I will remove my hand and thou shalt see
my back Parts but my face shall not be
seen twice very directly God told Moses
you cannot see my face
anything else we read must be understood
in the light of these very clear texts
Exodus 33 20 and exodus 33 23 you cannot
see my face whatever the Israelites saw
was a representation of God it was not
God's face
no human being
carrying the carnal nature can look into
the face of God and live and so no you
cannot see God's face you may see
evidence of God you may see a burning
fire you may see a dark cloud you may
see a mountain shaking you may see all
of these things you know that's God but
to literally see the face of God no one
has done that amen you can't do that and
live and in that case then we would
believe based on the clear text that you
know when Jacob is wrestling with the
angel he is not seeing he's not looking
into the face of God now Abraham spoke
to God but God took on human form in
Genesis 18. he came with two angels He
this was Christ in human form this is
not the Incarnate Christ the Incarnate
Christ had to come through a woman but
on previous occasions Christ came in
human form and he talked face to face
with Abraham but his divinity was veiled
by this human form that he took no one
can look into full Divine face of God
and survive amen
question number two is it sinful for a
woman to give birth to a baby on Sabbath
permit me to laugh a little bit someone
apparently said that I said in a sermon
that it is illegal to give birth on the
Sabbath I don't know where he said it
I'd like to see the clip so I can repent
internationally what I've said in the
past we should avoid sexual activity on
the Sabbath by husbands and wives let me
be clear husbands and wives avoid sexual
activity on the Sabbath someone told me
once well it was given to spouses as a
gift it's a holy thing and I responded
God gave the Israelites he gave Adam and
Eve work before there was sin but they
were not allowed to do that work on the
Sabbath everything that is right is not
necessarily fit for the Sabbath work is
Right work is proper work was invented
by God the very first person to work was
God but you're not to do it on the
Sabbath when God came down Was preparing
to come down on Sinai to deliver the Ten
Commandments he told Moses get the
people ready and in verse 15 of chapter
19 part of the preparation was this and
Moses said unto the people be ready
against the third day come not at your
wives
he told them no sexual activity in
preparation to be God we don't know what
day of the week it was but Moses
passed on the instruction from God avoid
sexual activity in preparation for this
unusual appearance of God and so we see
that sexual activity was banned
temporarily in preparation now praying
wasn't banned
you never been praying fasting wasn't
banned sexual activity was temporarily
prohibited as a part of a spiritual
preparation to meet God but I've never
said it is a sin for a woman to give
birth on the Sabbath day I've never said
that okay no thank you
another question is based on Leviticus 5
17 and if he will permit me I would read
the text before the question
Leviticus 5 17 says if a person sins and
commits any of these things which are
forbidden to be done by the Commandments
of the Lord though he does not know it
yet he is guilty and shall bear his
iniquity question is please help me
understand what that means now here's
another opportunity where we go to very
clear texts
John 15 22 if I had not come and spoken
unto them they had not had sin if a
person does not know acts 17 verse 30 in
the times of these ignorance of this
ignorance God winter but now commandeth
men everywhere to repent when a person
does not know God does not pronounce
judgment so clearly that text has to
imply that when the person comes to an
awareness of what he or she has done
then the person must take the necessary
steps and actions because in verse 15 of
the same chapter the Bible talks about a
person doing something on offense
against God ignorantly then that person
has to take some steps only when the
person has been made aware and so while
it looks as if an ignorant person is
held guilty know only when that person
has come to the awareness I have sinned
because Jesus who gave the sacrification
system he tells us clearly in John 15 22
if I had not spoken to them they had not
had sin and so the deck the text must
imply when the person becomes aware you
see an ignorant sin is still a sin it
has still been committed whether you
know it or not it's a sin it hurts you
God does not hold you responsible but he
wants to bring to your attention you're
doing something that's hurting you and
hurting him when that awareness arrives
then the person takes the necessary
steps but in a case of genuine ignorance
God does not hold that person
responsible and by the way genuine
ignorance means I don't know and I had
no way of knowing or I did not know and
I had no way of knowing that is
ignorance in the eyes of God not don't
tell me that's not ignorance that's
arrogance they sound alike but they're
different genuine ignorance is I did not
know I had no way of knowing and I thank
God for that addition at the end because
there's somebody who would say I don't
want to read the Bible that's right so
that I'm not held account that's right
that's a that's a self-destructive
attitude or I don't want to go to church
listen to someone to a Bible study
because then I'll be held accountable I
was conducting a series of meetings out
in Detroit the city of Detroit and the
lady came the first week we ran for
three weeks at the end of the first week
I did not see her again so I called her
on the job and I said I haven't seen you
she said Elder skeet I cannot keep
sitting under that preaching because if
I continue to come I will have to make a
decision and so she stopped coming that
is not ignorance that's suicide
next question thank you
based on Exodus 3 34 rather verse 6 and
7 which reads
and the Lord shall pass by before him
and procla and the Lord passed by before
him and proclaimed the Lord the Lord God
must fool and gracious long-suffering
and abundant in goodness and Truth
keeping Mercy for thousands forgiving
iniquity and transgression and sin and
that will by no means clear the guilty
visiting the iniquity of the fathers
upon the children and upon the
children's children until the third and
the fourth generation the question comes
all right how can God both forgive and
at the same time punish sin or if you
will
how can he be merciful and yet destroy
sinners
the very first words God ever spoke to
humanity
were a warning
as far as the Bible records Genesis 2 16
17 and the Lord God commanded the man
saying of every tree of the garden thou
mayst freely eat but of the tree of the
knowledge of Good and Evil Thou shalt
not eat of it for in the day thou eatst
thereof Thou shalt surely die the very
first words God ever spoke that are
recorded he may have said something
earlier but that our recorded
constituted a warning there is a penalty
there is a punishment
for violation of my law that is what sin
is and so a God of Mercy cannot tolerate
sin
we must not confuse God's mercy with a
willingness to tolerate anything we do
to just indulge us oh no no no God's
very character is wrapped up in the way
he responds to sin God threw Lucifer out
who became Satan because of sin then God
cannot deal favorably with those who are
determined to continue sinning because
the mind of Satan and the mind of a
sinner is no different the only
difference is Satan's mind is more
intense but it's really The Same Spirit
of rebellion and so a righteous God is a
God who will always punish what's wrong
whether he punishes it in me because I'm
deliberately rebellious or he punishes
it in Christ when I put my trust in him
sin must be punished regardless of age
when the Angels Came to Sodom in Genesis
19 to sodomize two angels the Bible says
both all old and young came when the
crowd brought the woman to Jesus in John
10 and Jesus somehow dispersed them by
convicting them of their own sins the
Bible says they left beginning at the
eldest even unto the least suggesting
they were children present as well as
adults
sin at any age must be punished by God
punishing sin is an act of righteousness
because the Bible tells us in Psalm 145
verse 17 the Lord is righteous in all
his ways and holy in all his works when
he punishes sin he is acting righteously
now you read the second commandment
visiting the iniquity of the fathers
upon the children it does not mean god
holds a child guilty for the father's
sin but the child suffers the
consequences so a woman smokes crack or
whatever some drug and the child in her
womb develops an addiction for that
substance even though the child never
made a moral decision to smoke but the
child suffers the consequences but the
child does not emerge guilty of smoking
crack but the child emerged suffering
the consequences
when Jesus died for us his death
provided benefits for the entire world
the same way Adam's sin affected us
negatively Christ sacrifice affected the
whole world positively and so there are
consequences good and bad sin has
consequences that affect those who have
not committed to sin righteousness has
not expressed righteousness it works
both ways but a just God must punish sin
okay and that reminds me of the Ark of
the Covenant where we have the law of
God above be beneath The Mercy Seat
that's right Justice and mercy they work
together not in opposition they were
together it's such a beautiful
cooperation the Angels don't fully
understand that's why in the
architecture of the Ark we have two
angels one on either side and they are
looking down at the mercy seat
symbolizing trying to understand how a
God of Justice can also show Mercy he
must exercise both the science of
Salvation thank you next question is
I have prayed for a long time and
apparently God isn't answering my prayer
what can I do
in Luke 18 verse from verse 1 to verse 8
we have a parable of the unjust judge
and in verse 1 Jesus tells why he gave
it a parable to this end that men ought
always to pray and not to faint the
person says she's been praying or he for
however long maybe a year or so
Abraham prayed 25 years before he had
Isaac Jacob prayed 20 years before he
had Esau and Jacob I am not suggesting
everyone must pray 20 years I'm simply
saying we do not we cannot tell God when
to answer the prayer God may be waiting
until you are ready
to receive the answer you know we ask
God for something we assume we are ready
to receive it we might not be ready
someone may pray Lord I want a husband I
want a wife and the person is not ready
for a husband or a wife it is not that
God does not want to give it are you in
a position to receive it is it the right
time and so we pray trusting God but
also we ask ourselves is there something
I am doing that is blocking the prayer
the Bible says if I regard iniquity in
my heart the Lord will not hear me the
Bible says he that turneth away his ear
from hearing the law even his prayer
shall be an Abomination the Bible tells
us and whatsoever we ask we receive of
him because we keep his Commandments and
do those things that are pleasing in his
sight all of those are conditions by the
way those verses are Psalm 66 18
Proverbs 28 9 and First John 3 22. there
are conditions for receiving and of
course praying according to God's will
but don't give up because God hasn't
answered you when you want to be
answered the final voice is God not the
person praying we pray in faith we obey
God and we let him decide when he will
answer our prayer he may decide the
answered prayer is harmful so I will not
give you what you want that's why we
live by faith in God he ultimately has
the last word and God's word is always
the wisest way keep praying whoever that
person was amen
by the way also pray the prayer of David
this one will be answered almost
immediately Psalm 139 verse 23 and 24
search me o God and know my heart try me
and know my thoughts and see if there be
any wicked way in me and Lead Me in the
way Everlasting father is this something
in me blocking the answer to my prayer
amen it is never God's fault
okay
next question for time from time to time
I have very bad dreams and these dreams
tend to ruin the next day always what
can I do
Isaiah 26 3 tells us that will keep him
in perfect peace
whose mind is tear upon thee my
recommendation to that person I'm not an
expert on dreams I'm not Daniel but my
recommendation to that person is be
careful what you fill your mind with
during the day
fill it with the word of God the council
from Eloise writings do that and see if
there's a change and before sleeping at
night commit your mind to God in the
book our High Calling page 116 paragraph
two hello white writes your last thought
at night your first thought in the
morning should be of him in whom he
centered your hope of eternal life fall
asleep with God on your mind how do you
do that fall asleep with the word of God
a few years ago I was preaching in a
certain country and the young lady came
to me she said I can't sleep every night
spirits come and disturb me and they do
whatever they do to me and I gave her a
Bible verse First John 3 8 he that
committeth sin is of the devil for the
devil sinneth from the beginning for
this purpose the Son of God was
manifested that he might destroy the
works of the devil I told her confess
all your sins then take this verse read
it read it think about it chew it
swallow it bring it back up to it again
swallow it fall asleep on this verse so
that your mind is filled with God's word
the next day she came to see me she said
I slept for the first time
in months and that's not the only time I
have had that testimony my
recommendation to this person monitor
what goes into your mind during the day
let it be the word of God the writings
of God's servant keep your mind on God
regardless of what you do and see if
there's a change and make sure your sins
are confessed and put away the
foundation of all problems is sin
whether it's my sin or just living in a
sinful world the foundation stone of all
problems is sin amen you will keep him
in perfect peace
Isaiah 26 verse 3. amen next we have
someone asking why do innocent children
suffer why didn't God protect me when I
was abused as a child
my response may sound a little
harsh
there is no such thing as an innocent
child
the only innocent child ever born into
this world was Jesus Christ
every person born into the world since
Adam fell
comes into the world hostile towards God
from an early age
and so I have to say that it is biblical
it may not be pleasant to Mother's
listening but it is biblical no one is
born innocent now
we live in a world of sin the central
issue for God is not if I suffer as an
individual the central issue for God the
central issue of scripture is the
Vindication of the name of God the
clearing of God's name of false
accusations in Job chapter 1 and chapter
2 the sons of God came to present
themselves before the Lord you see Satan
accused God of dealing unfairly with job
he made that accusation before a
universal Council that met with God even
before that
in order for him to deceive Holy Angels
he had to have misrepresented God even
though we do not have the precise
transcript he had to have misrepresented
truth and God is truth and so God has
been falsely accused
the Gospel of Jesus Christ is not merely
for this little world as Eloy calls this
this atom of a world the gospel is for
the universe because the universe has
been watching God did he treat Lucifer
fairly
you see so God's name has to be cleared
even in Philippians 2 when the Bible
says and every tongue shall confess that
Jesus Christ is Lord to the glory of God
the father that's the ultimate purpose
the Vindication of the name of God yes
we're Saved By The Gospel but that
salvation contributes to the Vindication
of God when we see ourselves as the
central focus of the Bible we make a
mistake the central focus is God the
father and the Vindication of his name
not me not even Jesus let me explain
that when I say that I mean Christ came
to do the will of the father
and Christ is the center of the Gospel
yes but he came to do the will of the
father and Christ says in many other
places many places in the Bible
particularly John I only say what he
tells me to say I only do what he tells
me to do
God's vindication
that is the Central purpose of the
Gospel we're on this Earth for his glory
Isaiah 43 Verse 7 not for us and so we
suffer yes but our suffering can
contribute to God's glory
Jesus is suffering contributed
tremendously to the glory of God
by the way the greatest privilege God
can give to you or me is to die for him
to suffer for God is the greatest
privilege God can give to a human being
suffer for me die for me
next question
next question for someone who got
married before he or she believed in
Christ should they divorce and get
remarried get get to marry a new
someone who
had no relationship with Christ
and is married
someone who didn't know Jesus Christ had
not given their hearts to Jesus they
were in they got married at that time
eventually they get to give their hearts
to Christ should they divorce and start
over oh no no no no no no no the Bible
is clear if the unbelieving partner
wants to stay stay in First Peter
chapter 3 from verse one to three Peter
gives counsel to a believing wife who is
connected to an unbelieving husband
she said the council is let him see your
faithful life
respect him as your spouse
that is how the world will reach him
that spirit is counsel to the believing
wife it also works for the believing
husband with an unbelieving wife let
that person see this Jesus in you
that is the council the Bible gives to a
believing person attached to an
unbelieving person but don't divorce the
person no you're married okay thank you
based on Matthew 10 16 let me read what
it says all right behold I send you out
as sheep in the midst of walls therefore
be wisest Serpent and as unhomeless as
doves what does this text mean Pastor
when God
Christ called the disciples the twelve
in Matthew 10.
they all named it from verse two to four
then he sends them out to preach he
tells them I am sending you as sheep in
the midst of wolves now since you're
aware
of what your audience is like
I am placing a burden on you
to figure out
how to get along
so that the work I'm sending you to do
is not held back it's not hampered it's
not uh in any way destroyed you have to
so monitor your behavior that it does
not hurt the gospel which is another way
of telling us that when we do God's word
our first concern is me will I be safe
will I be shocked will my head be cut
off my first concern is I need to
preserve this message I need to do
nothing that will harm the gospel the
gospel is more important than me and so
Jesus says be wise as serpents
and harvested don't do anything to bring
on unnecessary opposition he does not
tell the Wolves here is how you treat my
people he tells his people here is how
to deal with wolves in Romans 12 verse
18 something similar if it be possible
as much as life in you the believer live
peaceably with all men
as much go as far as you can
you stop when the law of God is
threatened now you have to stop
but Jesus calls upon his people do
everything you can to live a peaceful
life in a sinful world so that my work
is not hindered
yeah man
our last question before we take the
break all right when should one be
baptized or there are several responses
to that
when she won't be baptized or
re-baptized
re-baptizing rebaptize yes okay
rebaptism may be necessitated by one
the person was baptized when he or she
was too young and did not know what was
going on the parents probably said get
baptized and the parents commanded
conversion you cannot command conversion
but a child obediently got wet not
baptized got wet now the child has come
to the point of knowledge an individual
Choice the child needs to be re-baptized
or they might have been no Force but the
child got baptized because his friends
were getting baptized so he jumped into
the pool no baptism requires a knowledge
of who Christ is a knowledge of who you
are as a sinner and your need for Christ
baptism requires repentance and put away
of sin and then going into the outward
symbol which is baptism
the person who may have been baptized
knowing what he or she was doing but
drifted from Christ left the church left
Christ went off into life of sin the
person needs to re-enter that
relationship through the baptismal
ceremony also there are people in the
church who they're not adulterers
they're not murderers they're not
thieves but they have never grown in
Grace
they've been in the church 25 years and
the life has been this but not really
this has been this but they followed the
habit of going to church but they have
not grown that person ought to decide
listen let me start again all over with
Christ I was preaching in a certain
country and I made a call for re-baptism
50 people came
and I spoke to them in a room somewhere
and a retired Minister joined me
and he gave his testimony in the middle
of his ministry he decided I need to be
re-baptized
because he had not grown in Christ he
was doing nothing catastrophic he hadn't
run off with four or five women or two
men you know he nothing of the sort but
he hadn't grown
he wanted to start afresh with his
savior and he told a conference
president I need to be re-baptized he
said we'll baptize you at night he said
no baptize me in front of my church
because they're members of the church
who need to be re-baptized and so
re-baptism may be needed in a case like
that now in the book evangelism page 375
paragraph two alawite writes when a soul
is truly reconverted let that Soul be
re-baptized reconversion must take place
among the members and so that's another
reason some people they attend a series
of meetings and they are genuinely
reconverted
rebaptism is perfectly in order in
Exodus not Exodus Acts chapter 19 verses
1 to 7 we have the account of 12
disciples who were re-baptized by Paul
why they lacked any knowledge of the
Holy Spirit you cannot have a
relationship with God and have no clue
about the Holy Spirit when they receive
this significant knowledge they were
re-baptize so a person with an absence
of critical knowledge having received it
should make a decision to be baptized or
re-baptized
what did the high priest wear on the day
of atonement as he went into the most
holy place did he wear white as
Leviticus 16 says yes he did in
Leviticus 16 verse 4 very clear and he
shall put on the holy linen Court
and he shall have the linen breaches
upon his flesh and shall be girded with
the linen garden and with the linen
Mighty shall he be attired everything
was linen so yes he wore white when he
was finished with his intercessory work
in the sanctuary on his way out he
changed garments and put on different
garments but for the bulk of the
ministry he wore simple linen white
representing of course the righteousness
of Christ the reason he changed garments
because when his intercessory work is
done he's no longer a priest now he's
the king symbolizing he's coming for his
kingdom so when Christ comes in
Revelation we see him in John Revelation
14 he has a crown on his head the high
priest wore miter so that tells us
clearly Christ is not coming as a priest
to give anyone a second chance to repent
all that is gone he's coming as a king
but in the intercessory work he wears
white as the priest wore
in the Earthly Sanctuary yes so we can
believe Leviticus 16 4. thank you
next is what sin cannot be forgiven
simple the sin that is not confessed
first John chapter 1 verse 9. if we
confess our sins he is faithful and just
to forgive us our sins and to cleanse us
from all unrighteousness now Matthew 12
31 32 tell us all manner of sin and
blasphemy shall be forgiven unto men but
the blasphemy against the Holy Ghost
shall not be forgiven unto man and
whosoever speaketh the word against the
Son of God it shall be forgiven him but
whosoever speaketh against the Holy
Ghost it shall not be forgiven to him
neither in this world neither in the
world to come
that's one version of impartmeable sin
and the reason why Christ said that is
because when he healed a blind and dumb
man in verse 22 in verse 24 the Pharisee
said this fellow doth not cast out
Devils but by the elzebub he accused
Christ of using Satan's power to do
God's work now that's the ultimate
insult
if that's not confessive repented of
that's an unpardonable sin that's why in
36 Jesus said Every Idle word that men
shall speak they shall give an account
that was an idol word this fellow doth
not cast out Devils but by the algebra
that was the idle word that was spoken
and so Jesus says blasphemy against the
Holy Ghost is not forgiven because the
Holy Ghost ceases to speak to you when
the spirit you see it is the spirit of
that conviction not the Father the Son
the spirit is the convicting power when
you and I resist and resist and resist
we cease to hear the voice we develop an
immunity a hardness against that voice
we no longer hear it we have wounded and
grieved the Holy Spirit there's no
pardon because there's no seeking of
forgiveness
and so the impartable sin essentially is
a sin does not confess also it may be
attributing God's work to Satan that's a
terrible crime to commit against God
constantly resisting the spirit's
conviction to the point where you no
longer feel or hear the voice and
barnable sin but let me say this by way
of comforting those who are listening if
you are wondering have I committed the
impartable sin you have not committed it
because the person who has no longer has
those feelings if you're wondering has
God left me what did I do you have not
committed the unpardonable sin the
person who does that ceases to have any
real feelings one way the person may
come to church
but really has no strong feelings about
God
so if you're troubled that's a good sign
but obey yield confess do what's right
quickly
okay thank you
next here we have is the gift of tongues
one of the marks of conversion no the
gift of tongues is not a sign of
conversion at all
known as more converted than Christ if I
can use that term for him Christ never
spoke in tongues there is no record of
Paul ever speaking in tongues even
though he tells us in First Corinthians
14 verse 18 I speak in tongues more than
all of you 18 and 19. he said I can
but he said I prefer to speak five words
intelligently than ten thousand words in
an unknown tongue you know this is the
kind of question I can take an hour
because it I am baffled how people read
the Bible and still believe that tongues
is a sign the only reliable sign of
genuine conversion is obedience to the
law of God let me say it again for
someone who may not be listening too
clearly the only evident sign of
conversion or Genuine sign is obedience
to the law of God you know Jesus says in
Luke 6 46 why call ye me Lord Lord and
do not the things that I say
and so obedience is a sign but
there are gifts of the Spirit one of
them is tongues we are introduced to
tongues in Acts chapter 2. and they were
dwelling at Jerusalem Jews devout men
from under every nation under Heaven
Acts chapter 2 verse 5. Jews came from
all over the Empire Roman Empire and
other places to celebrate three main
feasts Pentecost was one of them they
had been gone so long for Generations
you know they had been scattered abroad
they no longer spoke Hebrew
here they are at Pentecost
this is about 10 days after Christ has
gone back
how are they to get this message
the Holy Ghost comes on these disciples
and gives to them the gift of time verse
4 says of Acts 2 and they began to speak
in other tongues as the spirit gave the
materials now in verse 6 the Bible says
now when this was noised abroad the
multitude came together were confounded
because that every man heard him speak
in his own language
what does that mean they did not hear
gibberish they heard the Bible is clear
everyone when the disciples spoke in
tongues every nationality heard his
language or hers now we have a
representative sample of the of the
Nations verse 9 parthians needs elamites
dwells in Mesopotamia and in Cappadocia
in Asia in Pontius you know phrygia
pamphilia Egypt the parts of Libya about
Cyrene Rome you know Crete Arabia in
verse 11.
those Nations that's just a sample
they heard in their own tongues which
means they were listening to legitimate
languages
I
challenge anyone with great respect you
go tomorrow or whenever
to a church where people speak in
tongues every Sunday at 11 or 12.
tell me if someone interprets
the Bible says if there's no
interpretation no one will speak in
tongues now in First Corinthians 14
verse 27 If any man speak in an unknown
tongue Let It Be by two or at the most
three
and that by course what it means is one
at a time that's what the Bible says to
those who read honestly
that's not what happens
in the churches that emphasize tongues
everyone speaks at the same time
verse 33 says God is not the author of
confusion
that is confusional let me be very blunt
if God is not the author of confusion
and the confusion means everyone's
speaking at the same time who is the
author of that and I leave my listeners
to come to the proper conclusion in
verse 28 of First Corinthians 14 the
Bible says if there be no interpretation
let him keep quiet in the church or keep
silence in the church so we have a
difference between what you do in the
church and what you do at home in your
closet at home
you can make all the noises you want
between you and your God
no one else is affected but in the
church
let him keep silence First Corinthians
14 verse 28 and let him speak to himself
and to God
are you following me and so the Bible is
very clear if you go to verse 5
in uh First Corinthians 4. Paul said I
would that you all speak in tongues but
rather that he prophesied for greater is
he that prophesyth then he that speaketh
in tongues except he interpret that the
church May is receive edification so
speaking in tongues must edify the
church edification biblically means I
received understanding and I have grown
spiritually
no one interprets in those tongues
speaking churches no one interprets
because no one understands what's being
said
many years ago when I was a boy
my pastor
went to a tongue-speaking church
and he took a tip recorder with him
secret secretly
and he recorded someone next to him
speaking in tongues you know when the
time to speak in tongues and everyone
starts to battle he recorded this man
three weeks later he went back to the
church and he saw the guy
and he called him he said
can you recognize this do you recognize
this the guy said no
he said what's this man saying the guy
said I don't know
they might pass it all and that's you
speaking in town three weeks ago
the guy didn't know what to say
people who speak in tongues in quotation
mark do not know what they're saying
they never interpret because it is not
the spirit of God as and you said
something to me uh yesterday my password
is so eye-opening
speaking in tongues was given to the
disciples at Pentecost because it was
necessary for a purpose for a purpose
now to to give a person the gift of
tongues where everyone has Google
translate and everyone has you know
instruments and Technology to translate
instantly is like providing healing as
you said so correctly to someone who's
not sick there is no need for the gift
of healing where there is no sickness
there is no need for the gift of tongues
publicly where there is no language
problem
here am I in an English-speaking Church
the congregation is English I am English
the the country is English the county is
English the parish is English and I'm
speaking in tongues for what
here's a man who's healthy and I'm
giving him medication for what tongues
must be spoken with interpretation and
the Bible is clear only two should speak
in tongues maybe three
it must be one at a time First
Corinthians 14 28 29 and if there's no
interpretation there must be no public
speaking in tongues tongues do not
suggest a person's converted and the
things that go on in churches on Sunday
those things are not of God because
they're not done according to the
Bible's instruction
no one interprets no one knows God
what's going on and everyone speaks at
the same time all of these things
contrary to thus saith the Lord that is
not the work of God and I don't mean to
be harsh I mean to be direct
amen and as we read we find that the
gifts of the Spirit one of them being
the give the speaking of times
these gifts are given according to the
will of the spirit that's right he
distributes them as he will as he Wills
for which which means that he gives one
to one person one is appointed as a
teacher that's right everyone is not
everyone receive the same gifts that's
clear in First Corinthians 12 verse 8 4
to 1 is given by the spirit the word of
wisdom to another the word of knowledge
by The Same Spirit and it goes all the
way down to tongues and interpretation
of tongues and if you go down to verse
28 and 29 to 30 of the same chapter
First Corinthians 12 do all speak in
tongues the answer is no do all
interpret no do all have the gifts of
healing no do all perform Miracles no
the Bible is as clever as sunlight amen
but Sinners are determined to do what
they want to do unfortunately all right
so next question is please help me
understand these two verses yes the
person quotes you shall know them by
their fruits the second portion of
scripture is Judge not and you shall not
be judged their question is is not work
knowing them by their fruit equal as
judging no it's not judging at all
a tree is known by its fruits
we are required to determine what fruit
for instance you look at Galatians 5
19-21 now the works of the flesh are
manifest obvious
you see which of these adultery
fornication uncleanness lasciviousness
idolatry witchcraft hatred variance
emulations wrath Strife seditions
heresies enviens murders drunkenness
revelings and such like the verse says
they are manifest it's obvious that's a
sinful life that's not judging that's
just seeing the obvious
from 22 to 23 but the fruit of the
spirit is love joy peace long-suffering
gentleness goodness Faith meekness
Temperance we have two sets of of
outward Expressions one the carnal
nature two the converted nature you must
be able to recognize one from the other
that's not judging that is acknowledging
that sin that's righteousness
now First Corinthians 6 verse 1 do any
of you having a matter against another
go to court before the unjust and not
before the Saints the meaning a
Christian should not sue a Christian
that's what Paul is saying to the
Believers why do you go to court go to
the church and have the things settled
do you not know that we should the saint
shall judge the world and if the world
shall be judged by us are you unworthy
to judge the smallest matters verse
three knowing not that we shall judge
Angels how much more things that apply
to this life pretend to this life we
must
make decisions and make judgments we
can't judge the heart
we can't judge this
we can judge your behavior that's why
the church can exercise discipline if
the church cannot judge it cannot
exercise discipline
and the discipline must exist in the
church or the church cannot develop
holiness
them that sin rebuke before all that
others also May fear First Timothy
chapter five I believe is Verse 18 to 19
then that sin rebuked before all but how
do I know the person sinned I have to
make a judgment based on scripture I
judge your behavior I don't know what's
in here God judges that the church must
make a judgment
if you've got a head Elder who's always
late you've made a judgment he's always
late you've made a judgment you must
make a judgment a judgment but you're
not determining who goes to heaven or
hell that's God's business but you must
know that's through that tree produces
that fruit that's banana that's a durian
or whatever
and you respond appropriately that's not
judging a person's conscience
because if someone had judged Paul
before he was converted they would have
said this guy is going straight to hell
but they could judge his behavior he was
killing people having them killed we can
judge that
we can't judge the heart but we can
judge the fruit
thank you
next we have is it right to honor a
parent who does not fear or obey God how
in if so how should one honor such a
parent
the Bible says honor thy father and thy
mother commandment five it doesn't say
honor the person who is a believer
all parents should be honored but
when Christ was in the temple the
parents had lost him for three days they
found him in the temple Luke Chapter 2
from verse 48 and when they saw him his
mother said unto him son why hast thou
thus dealt with us thy father and I have
sought the soldering Jesus said to them
why is it he sought me whiskey not that
I must be about my father's business
Christ understood his higher Allegiance
was his Heavenly Father
that cannot change
the first allegiance of a child
is the god
because your parents can sometimes ask
you to do things that violate the Ten
Commandments I have had young people
come to me and complain the parents
wanted them to work on Sabbath and they
were Seventh-Day Adventists
and the parents justification was you
just graduated you need a job God
understands he does not understand a
parent counseling a child to sin that
child must say father mother I love you
I'll die for you but I must put God
first we are not called to honor parents
sinfully we are called to honor them
biblically and so the Bible says
children obey your parents in the Lord
a spouse must submit to her husband in
the Lord
because our first commitment is to God
and no circumstance can change that so
if your mother tells you take exam on
Sabbath you say no
I love you Mommy I love you Daddy I
cannot do that and you suffer the
consequences
and that Pastor would spill over even to
government as far as obeying God versus
the laws of man God first God first Acts
chapter 5 verse 29 we ought to obey God
rather than man the law was Daniel
chapter 3. then an Herald cried aloud to
you it is commanded o people Nations
languages that at what time you hear the
sound of the Cornet flute but salt with
dulcimer on all kinds of music he Fall
Down and Worship the image which the
weekend has a setup the three Hebrew
boys said no
then the law was passed to pray to
Darius for 30 days in Daniel 6. Daniel
said no and both did that risking their
lives
God always comes first and there is no
except exception to that rule that
principle God first amen even unto death
and so the fifth commandment honor thy
father and thy mother
cannot set aside our highest parent
which is God
thank you and the child can be a
greatest blessing to his Earthly parents
by being faithful to his Heavenly Father
amen
next which is partly related to what
you've mentioned before is should a wife
submit to a husband who is unfaithful to
their marriage covenant well whether
it's a wife or a husband well okay we
talk about submission okay
[Music]
yes
Calvary shows us God believes in
reconciliation
now the Bible gives one clear ground for
divorce let me use my words carefully
one clear ground for divorce Eloy gives
the same
that's adultery yes she has grounds now
to leave
but if she chooses to stay submission is
still required
you see marriage is serious business if
people would stop and think what
marriage requires fewer people would get
married
it is serious business biblically once
you're in your Inn that's really the
biblical ideal once you're in you're in
you can't leave because the wife can't
cook ugali you can't live for that
reason once you're in you're in the
world system is you get in you don't
like it get out that's not God's system
and so if the husband's trees or the
wife's trays God's preference is
reconciliation because when God put Adam
out the Hebrew word also means divorce
but he won him back through Christ you
see
he had to suffer conscience but he won
him back to Christ
God looked at Malachi 2 16 the Lord God
of Israel saith he hated putting away
he doesn't like divorce he prefers
reconciliation
God has every reason to divorce people
the church because we break his heart
all the time we go off and have
relations with Satan by the way we live
God takes us back he takes us back in
that sense he's submitted to our needs
and now we need the Salvation so he
submitted to that need Christ submitted
to our needs by dying I hope you
understand what I mean by he submits our
needs
and so if the wife chooses to stay
chooses to stay she still has to submit
to that husband
now if that becomes his lifestyle
she's free to go
because God does not call us to be
deliberately abused
suffering abuse is part of the Christian
life because righteousness will be
abused in a sinful world but God didn't
call you and say go get abused no no no
no no no in pursuing your Christian Life
abuse will come but no one goes seeking
abuse God doesn't call you to go get
abused if it happens yes but it doesn't
call you for that only Christ was called
for that because he was going to Calvary
he knew he came to go to Calvary
next question
next is
I used to be a strong Christian but I
backslade is there any hope for me what
can I do yes there's a lot of Hope for
you again that's why Christ died the
prodigal son he left went off to a far
country I mean far
the father took him back now in Jeremiah
chapter 3 verses 12 and 13 we have
beautiful language
go and Proclaim to the north and say
return thou backsliding Israel saith the
Lord and I will not cause my anger to
fall upon thee for I am merciful set the
Lord I will not keep anger forever verse
13 only at knowledge
thine iniquity that thou Hast
transgressed against the Lord God said
look
admit you've done wrong
come and say father I have sinned the
prodigal son said that I have sinned
before Heaven on you
I'll receive you says God it's not
difficult
only acknowledge that iniquity that thou
Hast transgressed
as we say fessa admit it I sinned
forgive me God forgives
God doesn't scratch his chin and say
well let me think about it
once you say I am sorry
from your heart he forgives so whoever
said that question yes you've drifted
from God
you need to come back you're coming back
he throws his arm around you
forgiveness involves restoration
so the practicals The Prodigal Son came
back the father gave him a ring which
was not jewelry it was the way they
signed official documents back then
there was a ring with a seal and you did
that so don't don't want anyone thinking
jewelry no that's how they signed he
gave him that ring of authority shoes on
his feet and the best robe He restored
him to full participation in the family
business
if you've drifted come back come back
you're coming back to God who's looking
for you With Arms Wide Open
amen and his invitation Isaiah 1 18 come
let's come together why did you leave
what happened come let's talk amen
next here is Romans 8 verse 3 to 4 which
I'll read before the question
for what the law could not do in that it
was weak through the flesh God did by
sending his own son in the likeness of
sinful Flesh on account of sin he
condemned sin in the flesh that the
righteous requirement of the law might
be fulfilled in us who do not walk
according to the flesh but according to
the spirit all right please explain
how
we are Justified without the law
we're Justified without the works of the
law in other words you don't get
justified by obeying the law because you
cannot
a sinful person cannot obey a Divine Law
Christ has to step in
takes our nature obeys the law perfectly
and offers that to us
we're Justified when Christ gives us his
righteous life which is a perfectly in
harmony with the law
a sinner cannot keep God's law
so if God were to say look keep that law
and I'll I'll save you can't do it
Adam did not need the Holy Spirit to
keep the laws he obeyed God naturally
says when Lucifer rebelled the Angels
were surprised there was a law they kept
it just naturally
that's the way it was before Adam sinned
after Adam sinned no human being could
keep law of God because now he invited
him he inherited the mind that hated the
Lord could not keep it
Romans 8 verse 7 because the carnal mind
is enmity against God for it is not
subject to the law of God neither indeed
can be a sinner cannot keep the law and
it is only perfect harmony with God's
law that constitutes justification
you're right with God what's the
standard the law of God which expresses
God's character and so Jesus came in
this condition
obese subjected himself to the demands
of the law obeyed it perfectly and he
says to us now you come to me
my Victorious Life I'll give to you
so you justified by what I did
because there's nothing you can do you
cannot keep that law
no sinner can keep a Divine Law
and so the law is not an instrument of
justification it is an instrument of
condemnation for The Sinner the soul the
sinneth it must die the wages of sin
death the law condemns The Sinner that's
all the sinner can look forward to
condemnation from the law
Christ came
and through Christ's life now the
synonym can be made right with the law
because the life Christ gives to the
sinner is a law abiding righteousness is
law is law keeping
righteousness by faith is really
obedience by faith
why faith faith in Christ
because you can't do it
and so yes we're Justified without the
law the law is not an instrument of
justification the law
the law determines yes that is genuine
justification because you are in harmony
with me
the law witnesses to the genuineness of
the justification Christ gives to us
because
the only way to be right with God is to
be right with the law
you see when in first John chapter 3
verse 4 it says whosoever committeth sin
transgresseth also the law for sin is
the transgression of the law and ye know
that he was manifested to take care of
our sin and in him is no sin now verse 4
says sin is a transgression of the law
verse 5 says Christ came to take away
sin
not the law
the law cannot be destroyed it cannot be
set aside
sin has to be removed he does that by
his sacrifice we accept that sinless
life and the law says that's what I want
so we're justified by the righteousness
of Christ which is imputed to us
and the same Christ gives us power to
continue that justified life
sanctification is growing in the
Justified State I hope you understand
that you see you you Justified you're
right you can't be more right with God
you're right or you're not
you stay in that right life now that's
the process of sanctification holding on
to justification Tighter and Tighter
with each passing day is a practical
definition of sanctification
and it goes on without ceasing all right
down to our last one yes
pasta is it right to conclude that
if our sins didn't take Christ to the
Cross he couldn't have died the only
reason why people die is because of sin
remove sin no death if Christ had not
taken our sins he would not have died he
came to take our sins he came to die in
order to die he had to take sin
where there's no sin there's no death
Romans 5 verse 12 wherefore as by one
man sin entered into the world and death
by sin
revelation 22 verse 3 and there shall be
no more curse in the new world why
because there's no more sin the curse is
death and so when Christ took our sins
he had to die because the wages of sin
he took them as his own even though he
never sinned he took them as his own
consequently he was treated as a sinner
he had to die if he had not taken our
sins what was the point in coming
to save us he had to take our sins
on himself
and still remain clean
that's that will be for another
discussion but the Bible tells us how
Christ could take our sins and still
remain sinless it tells us how but not
now
okay well thank you again oh you're
welcome and maybe you can lead us in our
last yes let's pray father we thank you
for your word it's really very good it's
sweet
if your people would spend more time in
your word we would lose this love affair
we have with the world and social media
whatever else weakens us spiritually
let those who listen meditate on what
they've heard let them do their own
studying father because you desire to
teach them but help them to remember the
principle of John 7 17 If any man will
do his will he shall not a Doctrine
meaning a willingness to obey is
essential to Understanding God's word
continue to use my brother and me to do
your work bless all those who watch but
a double blessing on their children save
us when you come in Jesus name we pray
amen amen thank you very much you're
welcome